[Musique]
la séance est ouverte
je vais vous appeler le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribuée il n'y a pas d'observation le
procès-verbal est adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
j'informe le Sénat que des candidatures
pour siéger au sein de l'éventuelle
commission mixte paritaire chargée
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restent en discussions du projet de loi
de finance rectificative pour 2022 ont
été publiés
ces candidatures seront ratifiées si la
présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
notre règlement
et la parole est à Madame Daphné
rachmadou pour une mise au point au
sujet d'un vote merci madame la
Présidente celle-ci concerne le scrutin
numéro 51 au pdfss pour 2023 notre
collègue Jean-Marie Janssen souhaitait
voter pour je vous remercie merci acte
et donner de votre mise au point elle
sera publiée au Journal officiel et
figurant dans l'analyse politique du
scrutin concerné
alors l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen
de trois projets de loi tenant à
autoriser la ratification ou
l'approbation de convention
internationale pour ces trois projets de
loi la Conférence des Présidents a
retenu la procédure d'examen simplifiée
je vais donc les mettre successivement
au voie
alors je mets aux voix le texte adopté
par la commission sur le projet de loi
autorisant l'approbation de l'accord
relatif à la restructuration de la
plateforme douanière de Saint-Louis bal
sur l'autoroute A35 en France entre le
Gouvernement de la République française
et le Conseil fédéral suisse la
commission des affaires étrangères est
favorable à l'adoption de ce texte alors
qui est pour
qui est contre ça tient le projet de loi
est adopté je mets au vois le texte
adopté par la commission sur le projet
de loi autorisant l'approbation de la
convention d'entrée judiciaire en
matière pénale entre le Gouvernement de
la République française et les
gouvernement de la République de
Singapour la commission des affaires
étrangères et favorables à l'adoption de
ce texte qui est pour qui est contre qui
ça tient le projet de loi est adopté je
mets au voile le texte adopté par la
commission sur le projet de loi adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale autorisant
l'approbation de la déclaration relative
à la phase d'exploitation des lanceurs
Ariane Vega et Soyouz au Centre spatial
guyanais la commission des affaires
étrangères est favorables à l'adoption
de ce texte qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient le projet
de loi est adopté définitivement
alors l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen
de la proposition de résolution en
application de l'article 341 de la
Constitution portant sur le
développement économique de la filière
du chanvre en France et l'amélioration
de la réglementation des produits issus
du chanvre présenté par monsieur
Guillaume gonta et plusieurs de ses
collègues dans la discussion générale la
parole est au président Guillaume
Gontard auteur de la proposition de
résolution et pour 10 minutes chers
collègues
avant que vous ne preniez la parole
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
les chronomètres sont en panne c'est pas
pour ça que vous allez pouvoir parler
tout le temps monsieur le Président
alors les services en mobilisés pour les
remettre en état de marche en attendant
nous utiliserons des chronomètres
manuels et je vous avertirai en cas de
dépassement de votre temps de parole
monsieur le Président maintenant c'est à
vous
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues c'est avec
beaucoup de satisfaction que je défends
aujourd'hui devant le Sénat cette
proposition de résolution initiée par le
groupe écologiste écossigné par plus
d'une cinquantaine de collègues de tous
les groupes de la datasemblée et que je
remercie une nouvelle fois vivement
cette résolution vise à encourager le
développement de la filière chanvre et à
clarifier la réglementation des produits
issus du chanvre cela aura été est l'un
des fils rouges de mon mandat apparaît
comme en Isère depuis ma participation à
la mission sur l'herboristerie de notre
estime mes collègue joël Labbé en 2018
jusqu'à l'accueil dans nos murs de la
deuxième rencontre de l'Interprofession
du chanvre au mois de mai dernier
entre temps l'Assemblée nationale s'est
saisie du sujet pour produire une
mission d'information hors norme la
réglementation environnementale 20 20 a
été adopté faisant la part belle aux
matériaux biosourcés la réglementation
incompréhensible sur le CBD à défrayer
la chronique judiciaire je suis donc
heureux de la place que prend la filière
champ dans le débat public et des
progrès accomplis même si beaucoup
restent à faire et c'est tout l'objet de
cette résolution qui invite le
gouvernement à accompagner cette filière
indispensable pour la transition
écologique et à clarifier une bonne fois
pour toute la réglementation sur le CBD
mes chers collègues me pardonneront si
je répète ce matin certains éléments de
mon propos du 3 février dernier c'est
d'ailleurs ce débat en séance demandée
par notre groupe où était apparu une
large majorité de vue sur cette
problématique qui a initié la présente
proposition de résolution
mais nous avons choisi en lien avec les
acteurs de la filière de ne pas évoquer
uniquement la Broglio juridique autour
du CBD mais d'évoquer toute la filière
qui même si elle se porte bien mérite
toute l'attention du gouvernement je le
disais en février depuis l'Antiquité le
chanvre a pourtant continuellement
habillé nourri soigner les hommes et
recueillis leurs écrits aujourd'hui il
fait encore tout cela mais pas que il
nous loge et peut représenter un
substitut au plastique les débouchés
industriels sont considérables mais
largement sous exploité la France et le
troisième producteur mondial de chanvre
le premier européen avec seulement 22
000 hectares les surfaces cultivées ont
triplé depuis 10 ans et devrait doubler
ces cinq prochaines années rappelons que
la culture du chanvre ne nécessite pas
de produits phytosanitaire ni
d'irrigation quelle restructure et
dépolluer les sols et s'inscrit donc
opportunément dans les rotations de
culture
mieux elle capte plus de carbone à
l'hectare que la forêt 15 tonnes par an
le chanvre est un four une formidable
opportunité pour nos agriculteurs en bio
comme en conventionnel a condition de
multiplier ses débouchés et ça tombe
bien ils sont nombreux et toute la
plante est valorisable les fleurs et les
feuilles servent à produire le CBD ou à
extraire des arômes pour la parfumerie
ces graines très riches en protéines
nourrissent l'humain comme le bétail et
les animaux avec l'oisellerie la pêche
la paille permet avec ses fibres de fer
de la fibre textile de l'isolant
thermique du bioplastique et des papiers
spéciaux et avec son corps solide la
chaîne vote de faire du béton végétal et
de la litière
s'agissant du CBD je laisserai mon
collègue Thomas dessus précisé les
choses nous demandons au gouvernement de
ne pas attendre le jugement du Conseil
d'État pour autoriser la vente au détail
des fleurs des feuilles du catalogue
autorisé que nous proposons d'élargir à
toutes les variétés contenant moins de
1% de THC on est actuellement dans la
réglementation à 0,3%. des milliers
d'acteurs économiques attendent la fin
de cette mauvaise comédie judiciaire ce
fou juridique mais c'est toi et
souhaitable pour personne nous avons
besoin de règles claires facilement
contrôlables et d'un encadrement adapté
à la fois dans la production du champ sa
transformation et son utilisation
pour favoriser les contrôles nous
demandons la cartographie de toutes les
cultures de chambre même celles ne
faisant pas l'objet d'une déclaration
dans le cadre de la PAC les agriculteurs
et la filière le demandent nous
proposons également comment Suisse
d'équiper nos forces de l'or de tests
portatifs permettant de mesurer très
rapidement le taux de THC de la fleur et
de déterminer donc sa légalité
s'agissant du volet alimentaire l'arrêté
de décembre 2021 ne règle pas toutes les
questions posées par la consommation de
CBD nous invitons donc le gouvernement à
définir les doses journalières
recommandées de CBD a exclure de la
réglementation nouvelle food les
produits qui ne sont pas enrichis en CBD
et à définir clairement les produits
issus du chanvre qui relèvent d'une
consommation de bien-être et pas du
régime de la pharmacopée
de la filière textile qui a rappelons-le
un impact carbone 5 à 8 fois supérieur
inférieur pardon et consomme un minima
deux fois moins d'eau que le coton
parfois beaucoup plus et ses variables
bien sûr en fonction des climats nous
sommes en train de passer un cap avec
une réglementation européenne plus
exigeante sur l'origine d'excessives et
avec l'engagement de grands industriels
du vêtement pour utiliser justement la
fibre de chanvre mais les lignes de
production et les outils industriels qui
travaillent la fibre de coton ne sont
pas toujours adaptés à la fibre de
chanvre et demande des réglages
importants il faut donc procéder à de
lourds investissements pour lequel nous
demandons à la puissance publique
d'accompagner les efforts engagés par
les industriels nous pensons notamment
au crédit France 2030 qui n'ont pas été
intégralement consommés et qui au-delà
des technologies de rupture chers au
président de la République doivent aussi
financer le retour à des savoir-faire
ancestraux quand ils sont aussi bien
adaptés aux défis écologiques
en s'appuyant sur la nouvelle
réglementation européenne sorte de
nutri-score des textiles nous invitons
également le gouvernement à mettre en
place un label textile biosourcée et
ensuite à l'utiliser dans les critères
environnementaux de la commande publique
s'agissant des bioplastiques qui
équipent principalement les tableaux de
bord des voitures je rappelle qu'il est
un peu plus un peu moins pardon de 30%
plus léger recyclable cette fois et que
sur le parc de 13 millions de véhicules
équipés il représente une économie de
100000 tonnes équivalent CO2 le
gouvernement devrait aussi le considérer
davantage dans son soutien aux filières
industrielles vertueuse les fibres de
champ peuvent aisément remplacer les
fibres de verre dans nos nombreux
composites et faciliter le recyclage des
études sont d'ailleurs en cours
notamment pour la réalisation des pales
d'éoliennes s'agissant du bâtiment il
nous faut concentrer nos efforts tant le
chanvre répond aux exigences de la
transition et rénovation énergétique et
limite nos dépendances aux hydrocarbures
au mois de septembre j'ai visité une des
premières entreprises proposant des
modules préfabriqués en béton de chanvre
de la chaîne vote de la chaux du bois et
vous avez un mur qui stocke 35,5 kg de
carbone au mètre carré quand un béton
classique aimé lui 126 kg de CO2 au
mètre carré vous avez une hygrométrie
inégalée qui nécessite extrêmement peu
de chauffage et de climatisation 70%
d'économies suivant le cerema l'économie
d'énergie évidemment vous avez un mur
biodégradable ou recyclable qui n'est
pas un détail quand le bâtiment est
responsable de 3/5 des déchets du pays
pourtant il reste encore des blocages
réglementaires notamment avec les règles
professionnelles le béton de chanvre est
plus qu'adapté aux exigences de la
réglementation environnementale 20 20 il
faut massifier son développement et pour
se faire former les architectes tous les
métiers de la construction ainsi que les
accompagnateurs rénov ou les conseillers
de Lana à l'utilisation des matériaux
biosourcés et grâce à la haine de
chanvre le secteur de la rénovation
comme du neuf d'ailleurs et de la
rénovation thermique n'est pas en reste
actuellement 90% des matériaux du
bâtiment sont issus de la filière
pétrolière aux minières et leur
transformation est considérablement
énergivore selon une étude de l'ADEME le
polystyrène utilisé en isolation émet
2,8 Tonnes de CO2 par tonne produite
alors que la laine de chanvre permet
elle de stocker à l'inverse du carbone
et également recyclable et biodégradable
ainsi en cohérence avec la
réglementation environnementale nous
invitons le gouvernement à fixer des
critères ou des bonus pour les aides à
la rénovation thermique ma prime rénove
est complétez Z en lien avec la
performance environnementale des
matériaux utilisés au passage cela vaut
pour le chanvre et tous les matériaux
bossés et je vous annonce en exclusivité
un amendement écologiste au PLF en ce
sens tout juste déposé sur le prêt à
taux zéro une fois que j'ai dit tout
cela vous l'aurez compris il faut
massifier la culture et l'utilisation du
chanvre et cela passe peut passer
notamment par une grande campagne de
communication publique à destination des
collectivités des professionnels et du
grand public promises notamment en 2018
par le plan d'action une stratégie
bio-économie pour la France mais jamais
pour l'instant mise en œuvre néanmoins
nous sommes inquiets sur les capacités
de production agricole pour 23 la guerre
en Ukraine a tellement fait exploser les
prix des grandes cultures notamment des
céréales que nos agriculteurs n'ont pas
d'incitation financières à planter du
chanvre cette année en 2023 à l'hectare
le chanvre apportera 20 à 25% de moins
que le maïs le blé ou causa aussi la
filière nous formule une demande
supplémentaire qui n'était pas saillante
au moment de la rédaction de cette PPR
mais qui nous semble au combien légitime
la reconnaissance sur le marché carbone
réglementé du carbone stocké par
l'ensemble de la filière
j'ai je le crois suffisamment détaillé
le bilan carbone phénoménal de la
culture et de l'usage du chanvre pour
vous convaincre du bien fondé d'une
telle demande pour cela la filière a
demandé un accompagnement de la part des
corps d'inspection de l'État afin de
créer un mécanisme de reconnaissance du
stockage du carbone au bénéfice des
producteurs car les spécificités de la
filière chanvre profondeur racinaire
poursuite du stockage de carbone dans
les débouchés sont mal pris en compte
par le modèle créé par le label
pacarbone la stratégie nationale bas
carbone pourrait également être
renforcée par une primo stockage de
carbone dans la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments pour notamment inciter
l'utilisation d'isolation biosurcée il
conviendrait enfin de favoriser les
matériaux biosurcés grâce à la réduction
de la TVA et on compte sur le
gouvernement pour obtenir satisfaction à
Bruxelles dans le cas de la refonte de
la directive TVA voilà mes chers
collègues une présentation succincte et
que notre collègue dessus complétera de
la résolution
du Sénat afin d'envoyer
une fil pleine de promesses dans bien
des territoires notre vote est attendu
par des centaines d'acteurs économiques
ne les décevront pas merci bon monsieur
le Président quand je dis stop c'est
stop non parce que si tout le monde
prend les 20 secondes que vous êtes
permis de prendre parce que vous aviez
un compteur et bien on passera pas la
matinée et il y a des personnes qui ont
des d'autres choses à faire derrière
donc je vous demanderai de vous
respecter les uns et les autres merci
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Madame Corinne Imbert
pour le groupe les républicains pour 5
minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
compteur fonctionne
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la proposition de
résolution que nous examinons
aujourd'hui permet donc de mettre en
lumière une filière parfois méconnue du
grand public à ce titre je salue cette
initiative qui permet ainsi d'évoquer un
sujet d'avenir sur le plan économique
pour nos territoires la filière du
chanvre
l'opinion publique ce patiente
généralement pour les découvertes qui
marquent une rupture avec leur temps à
l'inverse l'exemple du champ aux
symptomatique d'un réel engouement pour
une redécouverte
en effet si le sujet ne prend de
l'ampleur que depuis quelques années son
utilisation par l'être humain est
multicellulaire alors évidemment il n'y
a pas de méprise l'évocation du chanvre
fait souvent penser au cannabis et
souvent associé à la triste réalité du
trafic de drogue et de ses conséquences
dramatiques notamment chez les jeunes
je pense que la première des priorités
sur ce sujet est donc un travail
pédagogique il faut bien distinguer le
drame que constitue le cannabis utilisé
comme drogue et la filière chanvre qui
apparaît comme une formidable
opportunité dans de nombreux domaines
économiques le chanvre est une plante
qui permet de stocker le carbone c'est
une plante qui a bilan carbone
formidable qui nécessite peu d'énergie
peu d'intrants et peu d'eau pour sa
production elle peut s'utiliser dans le
secteur du bâtiment de la cosmétique de
l'alimentaire ou encore dans le textile
pour ce qui est du secteur du bâtiment
le crépi chauffant en intérieur sur du
bâti ancien ou récent permet d'éviter
l'usage de la climatisation le chaud
chambre absorbe l'humidité pendant les
périodes froides et le restitue en
période chaude alors que la sobriété
énergétique s'impose comme une priorité
nationale le champ constitue une
véritable alternative à nos modes de
fonctionnement traditionnel la nouvelle
réglementation environnementale des
bâtiments neufs la re 2020 va dans le
bon sens puisqu'elle met en avant les
matériaux biosourcés néanmoins certains
verrous réglementaires pourraient être
levés ou amélioré on pourrait ainsi
imaginer la prise en compte d'autres
critères que le coefficient thermique
comme les polluants ou encore le confort
de vie
il pourrait également être pertinent de
mieux accompagner financièrement la
production à l'usage des matériaux
biosourcés compte tenu de l'envolée des
prix des matières premières le champ
apparaît également comme un substitut
formidable pour remplacer la laine de
verre la laine de roche ou encore bien
sûr le polystyrène enfin il existe un
véritable défi autour de la formation
des professionnels du bâtiment afin de
leur ouvrir de nouvelles perspectives en
matière d'utilisation de la fibre de
chanvre dans l'isolation des combles et
des parois des bâtiments mais également
dans l'usage de la chaîne vote dans les
crépis isolants il est fondamental
d'informer les décideurs publics de ces
formidables atouts autre exemple dans le
département de la Charente-Maritime qui
m'est cher le projet territoire pour la
gestion de l'eau de la rivière de la
Boutonne travaille sur plusieurs axes à
savoir les aspects qualitatifs et
quantitatifs de l'eau ainsi que sur
celui de la protection des milieux
de plus il y a une véritable volonté
locale de trouver une culture de
n'existant pas de pesticides ne
nécessitant nécessitant un minimum
d'engrais tout en dégageant un revenu
correct pour les producteurs au-delà
d'apparaître comme une solution
intéressante la filière change demeure
la seule solution pouvant répondre à
l'ensemble de ces critères
il y a également bien sûr une filière
alimentaire du champ grâce à
l'utilisation à la transformation des
graines de chanvre en huile tourteau
farine ou encore chocolat une époque où
le circuit court et plébiscité par nos
compatriotes le chanvre permet de
répondre à ces nouveaux modes de
consommation la filière textile est
encore trop peu développée par rapport à
son potentiel je rappellerai à ce titre
que le jean de Nîmes était
historiquement produit à partir de
chanvre avant d'être en côte
au moment où la rémunération des
agriculteurs soulève souvent un émoi
légitime dans l'opinion publique cette
filière apparaît aussi comme source de
rémunération très correcte pour les
producteurs c'est donc un levier
économique qui vient compléter cette
formidable palette de vertus
caractéristiques du chanvre
enfin alors que nous venons d'examiner
en première lecture le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale je
tiens à saluer la prolongation de
l'expérimentation du cannabis
thérapeutique nous sommes encore au
stade embryonnaire côté prescription
sans un vrai statut de médicament mais
dans l'intérêt médical est
particulièrement encourageant pour
toutes ces raisons le bâtiment
d'utilisation dans le bâtiment dans
l'alimentation dans le textile en
médecine pour telle ces raisons et en
souvenir des cordages de champ fabriqués
à la Corderie Royale de
Rochefort-sur-Mer à titre personnel je
voterai cette proposition de résolution
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Madame Vanina
paoligajon pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 5 minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cette proposition de
résolution est une excellente
opportunité de parler d'une filière
chambre à la fois complexe et
prometteuse complexe car elle regroupe
de nombreux acteurs de toute taille et
concernent finalement des industries
très diverses ce qui en fait la force
mais aussi la faiblesse prometteuse
aussi et ce à plusieurs égards la France
est le premier pays ça a été dit
producteur de chanvre en Europe mon
département de l'Aube très à la pointe
sur cette filière produit près de 50% de
la production française un tiers de la
production européenne nous développons
cette culture depuis des décennies sur
ce territoire à forte tradition
industrielle la maison de la turque à
Nogent-sur-Seine utilise toute
flubersienne a été rénovée avec des
béton de chanvre l'industrie du bâtiment
place de grands espoirs dans les
matériaux de construction à base de
chanvre l'industrie textile très
polluante se tourne aussi de plus en
plus vers ce matériau alors où la mode
éthique fait entrer dans les consciences
la nécessité de changer la donne plus
largement l'utilisation du chanvre dans
certaines industries participent
activement de notre transition vers la
neutralité carbone cette culture cela a
été dit n'a pas besoin de beaucoup
d'intrants elle est très peu
consommatrice d'eau
ce qui limite les besoins d'irrigation
c'est un atout agroécologique majeur
dans le contexte du réchauffement
climatique que nous connaissons
le chanvre à la capacité de stocker
beaucoup de CO2 cela a été dit également
par mes collègues dans un laps de temps
très court un hectare de chanvre absorbe
sur une année environ 15 tonnes de CO2
c'est-à-dire que c'est exactement le
même montant que ce qu'absor d'un
hectare de forêt le chanvre est donc une
culture aux multiples externalités
positives notamment pour les soldes dans
le cadre des rotations culturales des
atouts cruciaux pour notre agriculture
mais pour que cette chance se transforme
en marché encore faut-il des débouchés
stables pour la filière bien sûr les
investissements sont indispensables être
au fait des réalités du secteur nous
permettra de gagner en compréhension et
donc d'agir en conséquence
d'après la proposition de résolution
dans cinq ans cette filière pourrait
créer autour de 20000 emplois et
représenté un chiffre d'affaires annuel
qui avoisinerait les 2,5 milliards
d'euros la France doit transformer
l'essai
je pense que la poursuite du
développement de cette filière
participera à la réindustrialisation de
notre pays à laquelle je suis très
attachée nous devons continuer à nous
battre pour faire émerger des champions
industriels et j'en profite pour saluer
les annonces récentes du ministre
délégué surgit de l'industrie sur les
stratégies de relocalisation
industrielle et le produire en France
dans nos territoires je pense que la
filière chambre peut servir c'est ces
impératifs nous avons de l'avance et
pourtant nous devons aider à structurer
cette filière
elle offre de belles perspectives pour
une
réindustrielle réindustrialisation des
carbonées excusez-moi consolider une
filière c'est finalement permettre à
l'offre de rencontrer la demande c'est
là qu'intervient l'importance des
matériaux biosourcés et de leur
développement à ce titre les points 30
31 et 32 de la proposition de résolution
sont très intéressantes les matériaux
biosourcés ont toutes leurs places dans
nos démarches de rénovation et de lutte
contre les passoires thermiques
nous devons faire en sorte de mieux
faire connaître ses produits à la fois
des professionnels mais aussi de nos
concitoyens
j'aborderai un dernier point celui du
CBD des janvier j'ai posé une question
au gouvernement sur l'avenir de la
filière après le fameux arrêté du 31
décembre 2021 oui une régulation est
nécessaire et la filiale n'est pas
opposée la proposition de résolution
mettant lumière les chiffres des
millions de consommateurs ainsi que des
milliers de points de vente les acteurs
auront besoin de stabilité je le répète
la position de la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne celle de l'OMS
également s'inscrivent dans une même
optique le CBD n'est pas un stupéfiant
avec ces taux de THC inférieur à 0,3% là
encore madame la ministre ne laissons
pas nos voisins européens faire tapis
sur le marché français s'il vous plaît
avançons ensemble dans un cadre qui
respectait à la fois la santé publique
et qui permettent à nos entrepreneurs
d'innover
en revanche certains points dans cette
proposition de résolution me semble plus
problématique je n'ai malheureusement
pas le temps de les détailler mais je ne
suis pas sûr de la pertinence de la
multiplicité des labels qui sont
proposés le point 26 concernant
l'élargissement du catalogue cultiva aux
variétés qui contiennent moins de 1% de
THC m'interpelle également toutefois et
pour toutes les raisons énoncées si
avant notre groupe les indépendants dans
sa majorité votre en faveur de ce texte
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Thomas dessus pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire et
pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en introduction le
président Gontard vous a présenté le
potentiel de la filière française du
chanvre d'un point de vue industriel je
voudrais de mon côté me focaliser sur un
produit particulier de cette filière le
CBD mais après en bulle tant la
confusion peut parfois régner un effort
de définition s'impose que l'on parle de
chanvre de CBD ou de THC on parle de la
production de deux espèces de plantes
très proches biologiquement si le champ
est une un produit issu du traitement de
la fibre de ces plantes le CBD ou
cannabidiol et le THC le Tetra
hydrocanabinol sont des molécules
provenant de fleurs
lorsque l'on parle de cannabis récréatif
on parle du THC alors rappelons-le pour
éviter tout amalgame le CBD n'a
strictement rien à voir nous parlons
bien de deux molécules différentes avec
des effets différents si le THC est
considéré à juste titre comme un
psychotrope avec tous les risques
d'addiction à ferrant d'un point de vue
médical le CBD n'engendre pas
d'addiction et les effets psychotropes
sont inexistants à ce titre il n'est pas
recherché lors des tests de dépistage
des stupéfiants par les forces de
l'ordre lorsque l'on parle de CBD en
tant que produit commercialisé on parle
d'extrait de fleur de chambre que
certains trouvent apaisants antistress
présentant un taux de THC inférieur à
0,2% c'est-à-dire très très largement en
dessous du seuil à partir duquel se
manifeste les effets psychoactifs
pourtant une certaine confusion existe
parfois dans les esprits et lorsque l'on
regarde l'évolution de la législation
autour du CBD on constate que cette
confusion règne jusqu'au sommet de
l'État et ce dès l'apparition de la
filière en France au grand dam de notre
filière agricole les premières boutiques
de vente de CBD apparaissent notre pays
en 2018 et certaines seront fermées
régulièrement par la police en raison
d'une mauvaise interprétation d'un
arrêté de 1990 daté et inadapté à ce
nouveau marché
pour y remédier en juin 2018 la mission
interministérielle de lutte contre les
drogues et les conduites addictives à la
brillante idée de distinguer le CBD
synthétique du CBD récolté naturellement
sans même mentionner le côté
scientifiquement inapte de cette
distinction celle-ci met alors la France
en situation de non respect du droit
communautaire européen non respect
confirmé par la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne en novembre 2020 en
raison d'une entrave au principe
d'égalité devant la loi et de
libre-échange au sein de l'Union le
gouvernement a pour y remédier une
nouvelle idée encore plus brillante
qu'il prend par arrêter en décembre 2021
autorisé le CBD en tant que molécule
mais interdire la commercialisation de
la fleur de chanvre ainsi que son
utilisation en infusion ce nouveau trade
génie administratif bien français ne
mettra pas longtemps à recevoir son
jugement mérité une suspension par le
Conseil d'État en janvier 2022 le
jugement au fond est encore attendu
ces deux décisions du gouvernement
témoignent bien qu'il y a là un malaise
une confusion une instrumentalisation de
la filière CBD dans des buts moraux et
une forme de déni de la science nous le
disons et nous le répétons le CBD n'est
pas une drogue même s'il contient des
traces infimes de THC il faut cesser
d'urgence cette confusion entretenue à
dessin car des emplois et une filière
agricole et industrielle ainsi que
commercial sont en jeu 1800 boutiques
spécialisées plus de 30 000 emplois si
l'on prend en compte la production la
distribution la commercialisation pour
satisfaire la demande de 7 millions de
consommateurs
tous ces commerçants vivent dans une
grande insécurité à cause de ces
revirements réglementaires et craignent
pour leur avenir si au contraire on en
finissait avec cette confusion
permanente et que l'on soutenait
réellement la filière on pourrait créer
des dizaines de milliers d'emplois
supplémentaires le CBD n'est ni une
drogue ni un produit addictif il est
utilisé il est utilisé dans toutes les
tranches de la société et à tous les
âges les Françaises et les Français
aiment ça madame la ministre
finissons-en avec la confusion
permanente et revenons à la science qui
fait bien la distinction entre les deux
molécules le THC et le CBD permettons
l'essor de toute une filière composée
d'emplois locaux et de commerce de
proximité le pouvoir réglementaire est
entre vos mains utiliser le à bon
escient et je laisse une minute
merci Monsieur dessus la parole est à
Madame Nicole Duranton pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants pour 6
minutes chers collègues
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues lorsqu'on
additionne toutes les vertus du chanvre
on ne peut être que conquis aucune autre
plante ne semble cumuler autant
d'avantages ne coche autant de cases
environnementales et économique nous
sommes tous d'accord ça a déjà été dit
par mes collègues le chanvre c'est
d'abord une plante qui consomme peu
d'eau au sortir d'une année marquée par
la sécheresse et alors que la question
de la préservation de la ressource en
eau est de plus en plus problématique
c'est un atout considérable notre climat
est particulièrement propice à son
développement un développement qui est
rapide puisqu'on trouve la graine et la
récolte il ne s'écoule que quatre mois
avec un rendement maximal une plante qui
n'a pas besoin d'herbicides de
fongicides et d'insecticides là encore
il s'agit d'une bonne nouvelle pour la
ressource en eau puisque cette plante
pas besoin pour se développer de polluer
les nappes phréatiques avec des
traitements ou des intrants chimiques
autre atout cette plante est aussi toute
indiquée dans leur rotation des cultures
régénèrent la terre et permet sur la
culture suivante un gain de rendement de
5 à 10% pour les céréales enfin le
chanvre est aussi un excellent piège à
carbone puisqu'on considère qu'un
hectare de chanvre absorbe au moins
autant de CO2 qu'un hectares de forêt le
chanvre a aussi l'avantage d'intéresser
de multiples secteurs ce qui lui
garantit de nombreux débouchés et là
encore mes collègues l'ont déjà dit dans
l'alimentaire les graines de chanvre et
l'huile de graines sont des compléments
alimentaires reconnus pour l'humain
comme pour l'animal dans l'industrie
cosmétique de nombreux produits
utilisent de l'huile de graines de
chanvre dont les vertus sont reconnues
dans le bâtiment la laine de chanvre et
l'un des isolateurs naturels les plus
efficaces le béton de chanvre est
également de plus en plus reconnu pour
la qualité naturelle dans l'industrie
automobile le lin et le chanvre ont
beaucoup de propriétés communes on les
retrouve d'ailleurs dans les matériaux
composites dans l'industrie textile les
tiges de champ possèdent une forte
résistance pour en faire des vêtements
et des cordages dans mon département de
l'Eure la coopérative de l'un d'une
bourre vient d'inaugurer une toute
nouvelle usine de théage la French
filature c'est une petite révolution
dans le milieu textile en effet la
Normandie terre de lin détient la moitié
des surfaces de culture en Europe mais
elle n'avait plus aucune filature le lin
étant systématiquement expédié vers
l'Asie avec cette filature on peut
désormais produire du lin 100% tracé
made in France pour la Bible cet
investissement de 5 millions d'euros va
permettre de produire plus de 250 000
tonnes de fils de par an et pourraient
parfaitement demain servir pour filer le
chanvre
en Normandie il y a un véritable enjeu
avec 10.500 agriculteurs qui ont plus de
60 ans et qui se préparent à partir en
retraite d'ici 2028 autrement dit un
agriculteur sur trois va arrêter et doit
être remplacé la culture de chanvre
pourrait constituer un marché
extrêmement prometteur et ouvrir de
nouveaux horizons à nos agriculteurs et
même motivés les plus jeunes à
s'installer ou reprendre les
exploitations familiales en fait cette
plante n'a qu'un inconvénient mais pas
des moindres il faut maîtriser illimiter
son taux de THC cette substance
psychotrope qui permet de la
différencier de la marijuana en dépit
des propriétés formidables de cette
plante de ses nombreuses applications et
de toutes ces perspectives prometteuses
il nous faut donc faire preuve de
prudence sur les produits de
consommation à base de Cana bidules en
effet le CBD n'est pas classé comme un
stupéfiant mais il s'agit tout de même
d'une distance à effet psychoactif dont
les risques pour la santé des
consommateurs n'ont pas encore été
complètement évalués malgré la pression
de tout un secteur et le fait que ce
sont les cultivateurs de chanvre de pays
étrangers qui profitent aujourd'hui de
notre marché intérieur nous devons
approfondir nos connaissances
scientifiques sur le CBD avant de
délimiter un cadre législatif le CBD est
aujourd'hui autorisé à la
commercialisation en France mais des
progrès doivent être faits pour mieux
contrôler les produits qui sont
aujourd'hui mis sur le marché la filière
qui voit dans ce débouché bien-être une
opportunité de développement pousse
notamment pour établir des normes pour
procéder à des contrôles de teneur mais
aussi encadrer les méthodes d'extraction
et d'analyse et fixer des seuils
réglementaires transitoires ce sujet est
technique mais il est fondamental et ne
supporte pas la proximation en effet
lors de l'extraction du CBD de la plante
chanvre il y a un risque de concentrer
aussi l'extrait en THC si l'extraction
est mal maîtrisée or celui-ci a un seuil
de toxicité aigu très faible une
réflexion interministérielle est en
cours visant à délimiter le cadre d'une
politique de contrôle pour écarter du
marché les produits les plus
problématiques la PPR propose d'ailleurs
des orientations intéressantes sur ce
point qui mérite d'être approfondi le
ministère de la Santé s'interroge sur la
toxicité du CBD et le ministère de
l'Intérieur sur son caractère addictif
le FSA l'Autorité européenne de sécurité
des aliments procède actuellement à des
évaluations plus précises du CBD et nous
gagnerons sans nul doute à définir nos
politiques publiques sur la base de ces
données scientifiques affinées même si
les résultats de ses études ne seront
pas connues avant plusieurs mois par
ailleurs il faut être attentif à ce que
le développement de la filière CBD par
sa rentabilité n'as pas mécaniquement
les autres débouchés qui sont porteurs
de souveraineté alimentaire ou
énergétiques pour toutes ces raisons
notre groupe le RDPI va s'abstiendra je
vous remercie chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Gilbert Luc de Vina pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 5 minutes
merci
même la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues si la culture du
champ a accompagné l'histoire l'humanité
depuis la nuit des temps cette plante a
bien failli disparaître au 20e siècle
avec l'arrivée de la pétrochimie la
France est restée le seul pays à
maintenir sa production c'est pourquoi
elle est leader sur le marché européen
aujourd'hui la nécessité de produire ça
sur durable et accessible à tous remet
cette plante au goût du jour elle répond
parfaitement aux attentes sociétales et
environnementales sans produits
phytopharmaceutique sans irrigation sans
OGM le chanvre est un réservoir à
biodiversité et absorbe autant de CO2
que la forêt la filière est 100%
française de la sélection
variétale à la transformation de plus
les produits qui en sont issus sont
compostables et recyclables en fin de
vie
avec la délégation aux entreprises nous
avons visité dans le département du
Rhône en mars dernier l'entreprise de
Sima Vicat à Feyzin situé dans la vallée
du Rhône sur la métropole de Lyon la
solution des blocs de chanvre à
emboîtement de Vicat a été primé par
l'Institut français pour la performance
du bâtiment cette solution brevetée mais
en oeuvre des granulats de chèvre chez
wonhot et un liant à base de ciment qui
lui confère des performances
exceptionnels un dépouché important pour
ce secteur qui se renouvelle totalement
la culture du chanvre peut présenter
l'un des piliers de notre
réindustrialisation écologiquement
responsable qui s'agisse de filières de
construction locale s'appuyant sur la
culture durable du chambre et du bois
qu'il s'agisse des industries textiles
locales beaucoup plus économes en eau et
en que l'industrie du coton qu'il
s'agisse du développement des
bioplastiques plus légers et
compostables qu'il s'agisse d'une
filière papier réinventée qu'il s'agisse
du développement des protéines végétales
pour diversifier notre alimentation
qu'il s'agisse des industries
comestibles pharmaceutiques et du
bien-être aussi je profite de ce texte
pour souligner que cette filière à usage
industriel n'a pas bénéficié du plan de
relance car ces projets n'étaient pas
prêts or l'accompagnement de l'État est
nécessaire pour la massification
industrielle de cette filière cette
dernière à l'avantage d'être en phase
avec les objectifs de neutralité carbone
de la France tout en étant une industrie
au savoir-faire local bien implanté
territorialement dans le secteur tessile
textile de chanvre est une solution
écologique qui est urgent de développer
pour transformer le modèle de production
pour cela les investissements
industriels conséquents sont nécessaires
la rémunération des producteurs est
également un enjeu majeur pour permettre
aux chandrières de répondre à la demande
en hausse de ces débouchés et de freiner
son diable et de ne pas freiner son
développement si nous voulons que les
qualités du chanvre et la dynamique de
cette filière soit reconnue il faut
également accompagner le développement
des matériaux biosourcés dans le cas de
la rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
formés informés incités le chambre doit
donc être au cœur de la relance de notre
économie pour accoître nos souverainetés
renforcer nos territoires et réduire les
impacts environnementaux de nos
activités
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Marie-Noëlle linman pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste pour 5 minutes
mes chers collègues le groupe cscrce
votre enfant faveur de la PPR qui vise
au développement économique de la
filière chambre et à l'amélioration de
la réglementation des produits issus de
ses plantes tout devrait assurer un
développement majeur de la culture et la
transformation du champ dans notre pays
les collègues l'ont déjà dit la plante
et sa culture parfaitement adaptée au
climat français peu d'utilisation d'eau
et d'entrant pas de destruction des sols
au contraire stockage efficace du
carbone les
usages sont variés vous l'avez dit tissu
nourriture bâtiment
substitut naturel au plastique et bien
sûr des vertus thérapeutiques alors
pourquoi de telles opportunités ne se
concrétise-t-elle pas en tout cas pas
assez passe une variété de chanvre le
cannabis produit des fleurs une fleur
aux effets PS drogue est considéré comme
un stupéfiant et au motif de combat de
cette plante et son usage les
réglementations sont restrictives bien
au-delà de ce qui serait nécessaire
instable freinant le développement de
cette filière très utilisée pour la
transition écologique
désormais il existe aussi on le sait des
variétés avec une très faible taux de
THC TETRA hydrocar nabinol
qui ne sont sans effet psychotrope sans
effets stupéfiant il faut le rappeler de
surcroît on sait qu'un autre principe
actif comme le cannabidiol ou CDD elle a
des propriétés apaisantes et dans
certains cas même apaisent des douleurs
que d'autres formes de produits
n'arrivent pas à
affaiblir et peut-être évidemment
issu d'une variété du cannabis mais
d'une variété le cannabis
mais on ne sait pour quelle raison dans
un pays de la rationalité
on a instauré une réglementation qui
n'était pas cohérente et intelligente
avec nos exigences sur la législation
contre les stupéfiants et d'autre part
sur une capacité à développer l'usage du
champ dans tous les domaines et même
pour la consommation de CBD car soyons
clairs il ne s'agit pas d'ouvrir ici ni
de contourner le débat sur la
législation du cannabis c'est un autre
sujet il ne faut pas entretenir cette
confusion or on a plutôt l'impression
que chaque fois qu'on est vu avec ce
problème on est on a les yeux rivés
là-dessus comme une sorte d'angoisse
alors que je le répète il faut avoir une
attitude rationnelle qui ne confond pas
tout
donc on a un mot d'abord sur la
réglementation du CBD nos collègues
l'ont déjà expliqué ont la main soit
évoqué ici sur les abrogliaux les enjeux
les incompréhensions moi je vais vous
dire une chose je pense qu'on est
actuellement des de la situation il faut
s'en tenir à la réglementation
européenne les autres pays sont pas plus
insouciants par rapport au risque de
santé par Auris au risque des
stupéfiants et il faut donc prendre
cette réglementation l'adapter à notre
pays de manière claire et en particulier
permettent l'usage directe de la fleur
et des tisanes de ces de ces plantes
car ils ne sont pas stupéfiants alors
j'entends bien nos collègues qui nous
expliquent l'Europe s'interroge sur la
révision de ces législations et ben
écoutez prenons la telle qu'elle est et
on évoluera quand l'Europe aura évolué
vous savez l'argumentaire on va attendre
l'Europe pour voir comment ça va évoluer
on l'a entendu sur les gafam on attend
toujours donc je suggère qu'on agisse
dans le cas de la législation actuelle
et qu'on évolue le moment venu ça
suppose d'ailleurs qu'on développe et
c'est dans la PPR des organes de
contrôle des tests il y a des tests
maintenant qui séparent les stupéfiants
cannabis et le CBD dont elle est teneurs
en THC d'autre part je crois que l'idée
d'avoir une cartographie des plantations
de chanvre permet premièrement de
contrôler ce qui serait pas légal et
plus facilement et d'autre part
d'assumer comment notre la première
évolue et c'est le rendez-vous de de son
développement
alors il y a dans cette PPL évidemment
d'autres sujets ah oui je voudrais
insister 90% de la consommation du CBD
en France qui se développe énormément
vient de produire de l'étranger donc
franchement c'est aberrant et c'est
d'autant plus aberrant qu'on passe notre
temps à dire qu'il faut regagner notre
souveraineté si chers collègues chers
collègues pour les autres
usages du champ je crois que le
consensus est assez large et on aura
l'occasion à l'examen des articles de
parfois nuancer mes propos merci
beaucoup
la parole était madame Daphné raqmadou
pour le groupe Union centriste et pour 4
minutes chers
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les multiples
qualités du champ
semble faire l'unanimité ce matin et je
vais redire peu ou ce que vous avez
précédemment entendu de mes collègues
des tout premiers livres imprimés au
15ème siècle au voile de bateau qui ont
permis de découvrir l'Amérique le
chanvre a eu au fil des siècles le vent
en poupe
la culture du chanvre ainsi discrètement
mais sûrement accompagné notre histoire
fleur fibre granulés ou chêne vote la
plante sous toutes ses formes est
utilisée dans des secteurs aussi
nombreux éclectiques l'agriculture la
pharmacie le BTP l'alimentation les
cosmétiques le textiles et même
l'oisellerie
de 2900 avant notre ère à la fin des
années 30 la culture millénaire du
chanvre est alors un impondérable des
sociétés humaines le chanvre et même
qualifié de produits de première
nécessité au même titre que le pain
jusqu'au 19e siècle
pourtant peut avoir la moitié du 20e cet
âge d'or se termine et la filière
dépérir progressivement souffrant de la
concurrence des plastiques et de la
malgame avec la production du cannabis
avant de connaître un nouveau souffle
dans les années 90 avec mes collègues du
groupe centriste nous souhaitons d'ores
et déjà être clair à ce sujet nous
voterons ce texte aujourd'hui afin de
promouvoir la filière économique du
chanvre et le sujet n'est pas ici le THC
et le cannabis substances psychotrope
oui la culture de chanvre est une
filière économique d'avenir pour notre
pays sous ces différentes expressions
leader européen en la matière la France
peut voir plus grand la filière doit
être à ce titre pleinement soutenu dans
le cadre du Plan France 2030 oui nous
pouvons nous appuyer sur le champ pour
contribuer dès aujourd'hui à bâtir notre
transition écologique
préservant la qualité de nos sols
faiblement vorace en eau et recoquérant
peu ou pas de produits phytosanitaires
le champ présente des qualités
écologiques évidentes que nous ne
pouvons ignorer oui la culture de
chanvre peut être un atout pour notre
agriculture en proposant une
diversification des activités et des
revenus complémentaires non le champ
n'est pas portion congrue dans
l'équation économique actuelle en 2020
cette culture représentait près de 1414
producteurs et environ 30 000 emplois
directs et indirects dans mon
département l'Essonne la culture du
chanvre c'est l'entreprise gatichambre
qui travaille avec près de 100
agriculteurs partenaires pour produire
1000 hectares de chanvre dans la moitié
en bio
cette société réalise la première
transformation du chanvre le défibrage
de la paille cela permet par la suite de
production de papier d'isolant de route
ou encore de biocomposites preuve de la
variété des productions de la filière
l'entreprise produit exactement de la
chaîne vote qui alimente les marchés du
pays de la litière mais également du
bâtiment pour les enduits béton et blocs
de chanvre je tiens donc à saluer le
travail d'excellence fait par l'ensemble
des acteurs du groupe en Gâtinais et
maintenant dans les départements
limitrophes
à l'aune des atouts de cette filière
méconnue je souhaite féliciter nos
collègues du groupe écologiste pour la
qualité de leur travail sur cette
proposition de résolution loin des
clichés éculés de l'inventaire à la
Prévert dépourvu d'intérêt c'est un
texte de qualité qui permet d'alerter
les pouvoirs publics sur les changements
nécessaires pour développer sereinement
la filière cependant nous devons rester
vigilants et nous attirer que nous
posons les bases d'une filière
souveraine et éco-responsable en
construisant des écosystèmes économiques
locaux et des débouchés industriels en
France chers collègues c'est pour cela
qu'avec ma collègue Annick Billon et le
groupe de l'Union centriste nous
voterons ce texte pour développer dès
demain avec exigences et ambition la
filière chanvre je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur Henri
Cabanel pour le groupe de Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen pour 5
minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
et chère collègue
il a fallu attendre une décision de la
Cour de justice européenne en 2020 pour
que la France autorise enfin les
extraits de chanvre et le 16 BD en tant
que molécule mais il le fera encore
compter sur le Conseil d'État pour que
la commercialisation de la fleur de
chanvre soit possible
les auteurs de la proposition de
résolution d'un souligné et je tiens à
les remercier c'est revirements
insécurisent la filière une filière qui
compte déjà 30 000 emplois directs et
indirects
si les aléas juridiques ne cessent pas
la France prendra retard considérable
dans le développement de la culture du
chanvre alors même que notre pays année
le premier exploitant d'Europe grâce à
des conditions climatiques favorables
bien entendu nous savons que toile quand
toile de fond il y a l'image du chanvre
et de ses
usages psychotropes en effet les enjeux
sanitaires n'échappent à personne mon
groupe soutient toutes les politiques de
lutte contre les addictions aux
stupéfiants la consommation régulière de
cannabis met en péril la santé physique
et psychique de nombreux jeunes il est
important de le souligner toutefois nous
trompons pas de débat la législation du
cannabis en étonnant
je le rappelle donc clairement ce qui
nous intéresse à travers ce texte c'est
l'avenir des produits CBD dépourvus
d'actifs psychotropes ou contenant moins
de 0,3 de THC HC il s'agit d'apprécier
le large potentiel le développement du
champ au regard de ses atouts sur le
marché le texte style la construction le
papier sans oublier ses vertus
cosmétiques et pharmaceutiques face à
cela comme nous y invite à la
proposition de résolution l'agriculture
française pourrait en profiter d'une
filière encore plus dynamique à
condition que le gouvernement près d'une
position claire et éclairée
mes collègues ont parfaitement présenté
les qualités du champ économano adaptés
pour la rotation des cultures et offrant
une qualité de drainage son exploitation
peut donc s'inscrire dans une démarche
durable et bénéficier de label comme
cela est proposé par ailleurs le
développement du chanvre peut être dans
certains territoires ruraux un pilier de
la reconquête industrielle le RDSE
souhaite toutefois poser quelques
conditions la première c'est que son
exploitation nos concurrence pas
d'autres cultures essentielles à
l'objectif de souveraineté alimentaire
que nous sommes nombreux à défendre sur
ces bancs sa bonne rotation avec
d'autres cultures apportent une première
garantie la seconde condition c'est que
sa production et sa commercialisation
répondent à des critères de sécurité et
de contrôle l'interprofession se dit
prête en contrôlera enfoncé des
parcelles de chanvre et à leur
déclaration pour la traçabilité des
fleurs
je retiens également les propositions du
texte quant à la conduite de test sur
les teneurs en CBD et THC des produits
bruts
les flux de marché doivent également
être surveillés pour cela le
développement de la filière doit
s'exercer dans un environnement
réglementaire sécurisé sur le plan
national comme je l'ai dit ainsi que sur
le plan européen par une Uniformation du
taux de THC le fameux arrêté kanavap
impose au nom de la libre circulation
des marchandises à chaque pays la
reconnaissance des teneurs légalement
fixés chez ses partenaires ce qui crée
des normes différentes d'un pays à
l'autre cette situation peut compliquer
la tâche des services de contrôle que ce
soit la douane et la direction générale
de la concurrence de la consommation et
de la répression des fraudes
enfin au titre des services que les
producteurs de chambre pourraient rendre
à travers le stockage de carbone ou le
développement de matériaux biosourcés je
souhaite que la monde de la filière soit
soutenue comme le son toutes les autres
mes chers collègues la culture du chant
représente un intérêt certain pour notre
économie disons-le aussi ses produits
dérivés répondent à une demande de
sociétale autour du bien-être dans ces
conditions la majorité de notre groupe
approuve la proposition de résolution et
vous demande madame la ministre de ne
pas laisser la filière perdre pied au
profit d'autres pays mieux préparés je
vous remercie merci chers
pour le groupe les républicains pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues nous examinons aujourd'hui la
proposition de résolution de nos
collègues du groupe écologiste qui
souhaitent alerter le gouvernement sur
les contraintes réglementaires posant
sur la culture du chanvre je vous
surprendrai certainement en vous disant
que je partage une partie de leur
préoccupations et de leurs attentes en
effet le chambre est une plante
disposante d'une formidable potentielle
d'avenir mais dont les débouchés sont
actuellement limités pour des raisons
dont la logique m'échappe pour nous
agriculteurs elle représente une
possibilité de revenus complémentaires
je parle bien de revenus complémentaires
car il serait totalement illusoire
d'imaginer qu'elle se substitue aux
autres cultures pour notre pays le
chanvre peut être un des moyens
d'atteindre une partie de ses objectifs
en matière de transition énergétique
grâce à son utilisation massive dans le
cas de la construction et de la
rénovation des logements toutefois la
proposition de résolution de nos
collègues mais l'action sur les
principes actifs de cette plante et les
usages récréatifs qu'elle permet c'est
sa principale faiblesse
or son utilisation dans de nombreux
secteurs de l'économie est possible en
particulier dans le bâtiment comme je
viens de le souligner beaucoup de
chemins étaient parcourus depuis la
première rénovation d'une maison
d'habitation avec un enduit constitué de
chaux et de chanvre en 1986 la filière
est aujourd'hui parfaitement structurée
avec un unique producteur de semences
certifié qui investit puissamment dans
l'innovation variétale afin de créer les
nouvelles variétés de haute qualité
adaptées au marché l'association
construire en chanvre et quant à elle un
acteur majeur pour les professionnels du
bâtiment elle est à l'origine des règles
professionnelles d'exécution d'ouvrages
en béton de chanvre qui constitue le
premier et à ce jour le seul texte de
référence sur l'utilisation du chanvre
dans le secteur de la construction
dans le cadre sécurisant et sécurisé de
plus en plus agriculteurs optent pour
cette voie de diversification
agronomique respectueuse de
l'environnement et prometteuse en termes
de retombées économiques mon département
l'Essonne est d'ailleurs l'un des plus
importants producteurs de chanvre
industrielles avec un millier d'hectares
en culture et une centaine
d'exploitation d'exploitant agricoles
mobilisés entreprise et sonielle
emblématique gatichambre assure le
défibrages de la paille première étape
de la transformation du chanvre
permettant la réalisation d'isolants
d'enduit de béton et de blocs de chanvre
comment dans ces conditions explique les
difficultés de mise en oeuvre des
produits
issus du chanvre dans le bâtiment certes
la décision de l'agence qualité
construction qui avait rejeté l'an
dernier les règles professionnelles
édictées dans le but de massifier la
construction en chanvre et derrière nous
et l'on doit se féliciter du soutien
apporté aux nouvelles règles
professionnelles dont la validation
devrait intervenir prochainement
mais une autre entrave à l'usage du
chanvre dans le bâtiment réside de
l'impossibilité pour les maîtres
d'ouvrage de valoriser financièrement le
béton de champ par le biais des
certificats d'économie d'énergie ce
dispositif requiert en effet une
certification sur les matériaux employés
garantis par l'Association pour la
certification des matériaux isolants les
règles professionnelles ne seraient
tenir lieu de certification or les
performances thermiques remarquables du
chanvre ses capacités hygrohermiques
inégalées son pouvoir d'absorption des
sons et sa résistance au feu sont
amplement démontrées un sujet
d'inquiétude supplémentaire tient au
fait que la plupart des maîtres d'oeuvre
sont des entreprises artisanales ou des
PME spécialisés ne disposant pas
toujours des moyens de financer la
démarche de qualité permettant
l'obtention du label reconnu garant de
l'environnement les maîtres d'oeuvre ne
peuvent donc pas prétendre aux aides de
l'État aussi de la rénovation de
l'habitat
enfin la filière manque singulièrement
de moyens pour financer des fiches de
déclaration environnementale et
sanitaires nécessaires au respect de la
nouvelle réglementation environnementale
2020 re 2020 tous ces freins normatifs
ont une conséquence majeure
l'amélioration de la performance
énergétique des bâtiments n'est obtenu
que par l'emploi de matériaux
issus de grands groupes industriels dont
l'impact environnemental énergétique à
la production et plus défavorable que
pour les matériaux biosourcés alors que
l'optimisation des ressources naturelles
est indispensable pour assurer la
transition énergétique et que la France
peut se prévaloir d'être le leader
européen de la production de chanvre je
souhaiterais que le gouvernement prenne
des initiatives importantes pour obtenir
la levée des contraintes pesant sur son
utilisation dans le secteur de la
construction en particulier il me paraît
indispensable d'accompagner cette levée
des restrictions par des mesures
fiscales propres à soutenir le
développement significatif des filières
locales bio sur C dans celle du chanvre
permettez-moi de vous demander madame la
ministre d'engager une concertation
interministérielle sur ce sujet c'est
assez con mais c'est assez condition que
notre pays pourra participer pleinement
et rapidement à la transition
énergétique rendue indispensable par la
hausse exponentielle du prix d'énergie
dont souffre nos concitoyens et dépend
entier de notre économie je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Claude Tissot pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues pour commencer je
tiens à saluer les auteurs de cette
proposition de résolution notamment
notre collègue Guillaume gonta et les
membres du groupe écologistes solidarité
et territoire alors que le sujet
d'affiliaire chambre semble être
récemment rendu sur le devant de la
scène il est important de rappeler qu'il
s'agit d'une culture très ancienne et
qu'elle a connu une institution en
France dès 1932 avec la création de la
Fédération nationale des producteurs de
chambre grâce à la multiplicité de ces
usages et de ses nombreuses vertus la
filière chambre possède déjà un point
économique non négligeable et surtout
des perspectives de développement
particulièrement importantes en effet en
2020 la filière chambre la filière
française du chambre comptait plus de
1400 producteurs pour 17000 hectares
exploités avec une surface de production
multipliée par 3 en 15 ans
grâce à ce dynamisme la France est le
premier producteur européen de chanvre
et le quatrième mondial et pour une fois
je pense notamment et c'est dommage il
est absent aujourd'hui aux auteurs du
récent rapport sénatorial sur la
compétitivité de la ferme France nous
pouvons collectivement nous féliciter
d'une dynamisme de cette filière
malheureusement cette culture a toujours
eu mauvaise presse principalement à
cause de la production de sa fleur aux
effets psychotropes le cannabis avec les
connaissances scientifiques et
techniques que nous avons aujourd'hui il
convient de sortir des clichés de se
rendre compte de la diversité des usages
et des bénéfices du chanvre en tant
qu'agriculteur je souhaite insister sur
les opportunités agroécologiques de la
production du chanvre en effet cette
dernière ne nécessite pas d'insecticides
pas de fongicide pas d'herbicides et
particulièrement économe en eau par la
hauteur et la densité de cette plante il
est également un formidable réservoir à
biodiversité qui peut pleinement
s'inscrire dans l'indispensable rotation
des cultures et dans l'entretien des
sols c'est donc une culture
particulièrement saine qui peut être une
puissante créatrice de vocation pour les
jeunes agriculteurs qui ont la volonté
de développer une agriculture plus
vertueuse plus vertueuse sur le plan
environnemental et ainsi apporter une
partie de la solution au problème du
renouvellement des générations face aux
difficultés économiques qu'on rencontre
de nombreux agriculteurs le prix de
revente de kilos de fleurs CBD à environ
600 euros pour l'année 2022 peut
également être une opportunité
développement pour le monde agricole
bien sûr pour permettre cela et c'est
l'objectif principal de cette résolution
il est nécessaire d'avoir une
réglementation adaptée à la filière
notamment en permettant la vente de
fleurs et de feuilles brutes et injuste
accompagnement par les pouvoirs publics
sous ces derniers points je rejoins
pleinement de recommandations de la
proposition de la résolution tout
particulièrement sous l'ouverture du
label Agriculture Biologique et cette
filière à cette filière et l'obligation
de déclaration des cultures pour être
incompatibilité avec les obligations de
la PAC comme pour toutes les filières la
labellisation et la mise en conformité
avec les critères pack permettront de
réaliser un cadrage et ainsi d'éviter
des dérives qui peuvent être facilement
associées à cette culture
enfin et sur un plan économique plus
global il est important souligné que la
diversité des usages du chanvre lui
permet d'avoir des perspectives de
débouchés dans des filières très variées
mon collègue et Gilbert Luc de Minase a
justement abordé les secteurs du textile
et du bâtiment et nous pourrions
également citer l'alimentation humaine
avec des graines particulièrement riches
en protéines l'alimentation animale avec
les graines de chez Venise et bien sûr
la filière papier avec près de 7
millions de consommateurs le CBD peut
être une réelle opportunité pour les
buralistes également dans le nombre des
minutes 27% en 20 ans et qui possède
l'expertise et les compétences pour
assurer la vente d'un tel produit ainsi
madame la ministre alors que votre
gouvernement s'est engagé à plusieurs
reprises à soutenir le développement de
la filière chambre il est aujourd'hui
essentiel d'apporter une clarification
sur la réglementation autour du CBD
comme le prévoit alinéa 49 cette
proposition de résolution seul un appui
aux acteurs de la filière et une
précision sur le cas de légal et
réglementaire permettront un
développement d'un développement un réel
développement de la filière française du
chanvre mes chers collègues en
soulignant encore une fois la qualité de
ces propositions de résolution et
différents objectifs mis en avant par ce
texte je vous invite à largement
soutenir l'adoption de cette résolution
comme nous le ferons au sein du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain je
vous remercie
merci
la parole est à madame la Présidente
billon pour le groupe Union centriste et
pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues si aujourd'hui les
voiles des monocoques du Vendée Globe ne
sont pas constitués de fibres de chanvre
celle de la flotte de Louis XIV l'était
la filière économique et industrielle du
chanvre ainsi connu ses heures de gloire
au 17 et 18e siècle avant de péricliter
la confusion compréhensible entre le
cannabis et la fleur de chanvre ayant
conduit à une
marginalisation de sa production à
partir des années 90 s'émancipant
complètement de l'ombre du cannabis la
filière renaît en s'appuyant sur des
acteurs locaux créateurs d'emploi nous
examinons aujourd'hui une proposition de
résolution à l'initiative de nos
collègues du groupe écologiste je salue
cette initiative car elle nous permet de
mettre en lumière de belles entreprises
dans nos territoires d'encourager une
filière tout en nous donnant aucun
signal en faveur de la légalisation de
la dépénalisation du cannabis
agriculture textile ou BTP la filière du
chanvre sous ses différentes expressions
à ainsi un véritable potentiel
économique qu'il ne faut pas négliger
cela fait ainsi plus de 20 ans que le
secteur de la construction et du
bâtiment s'appuient sur le chanvre tant
pour ses propriétés isolantes que pour
la restauration d'habitation je tiens à
saluer à ce titre la création il y a
bientôt 25 ans de l'association
construire en chanvre qui œuvrent pour
la valorisation de la filière depuis
deux décennies c'est ainsi toute une
économie qui s'est développée pour
favoriser l'utilisation du chanvre en
s'appuyant sur ses qualités
hygrohermique ça durabilité et sa très
bonne régulation de l'humidité que cela
soit que cela soit la chenevotte ou la
fibre de chanvre cette plante a des
débouchés économiques qu'il convient de
valoriser en Vendée cela fait plus de 10
ans que la coopérative CAVAC que je
connais bien a fait du chanvre un
matériel essentiel dans le cadre de la
construction biosourcée alors où la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments est
un pilier de la relance verte appelée de
ses vœux par le gouvernement il nous
faut donner les moyens aux entreprises
de la filière les matériaux biosourcés
doivent contribuer à la décarbonation de
nos bâtiments cette proposition de
résolution pourrait à ce titre être
utilement complété par trois dispositifs
1 l'élargissement de la formation des
accompagnateurs rénove matériaux bio
sourcé afin que les rénovations
financées par l'outil Mappy rénovie
également sur le chambre de une
meilleure valorisation de la capacité de
stockage du carbone du chanvre dans le
cadre de la Stratégie nationale bas
carbone 3 le lancement d'une réflexion
au sujet de la mise en œuvre d'un taux
de TVA en prenant mieux en compte les
atouts des matériaux biosourcés pour
conclure l'adoption de cette proposition
est un geste fort pour dire clairement
notre soutien aux acteurs économiques de
la filière producteur coopératifs
industrielle ainsi que l'ensemble d'être
en formateur avec plus de 17000 hectares
en France il est temps de donner à la
filière chambre un cadre légal stable
permettant à l'activité de prospérer
durablement et de se développer
sainement c'est pour cela qu'avec ma
collègue Daphné rachmandu et l'ensemble
du groupe Union centriste nous ventrons
en faveur de cette proposition
issue devant mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
merci la parole est à Monsieur Christian
Klinger pour le groupe les républicains
pour 4 minutes
et vous essayez de pas tomber là dans
les escaliers ça va bien se passer
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues tout est bon dans le
cochon à ton coutume de dire aujourd'hui
j'ai envie de dire tout est bon dans le
chanvre à la lecture de cette
proposition de résolution
au sortir d'un été marqué par la
sécheresse et à l'heure des économies de
chauffage le développement en France de
la filière du chanvre plante saubrando
et aux usages multiples paraît donc une
évidence c'est une plante qui pousse
vite résiste à la sécheresse et qui ont
faim ne réclame pas d'apport en produits
chimiques les chiffres de la filière
démontrent l'intérêt de cette plante de
moins de 4000 hectares en 1990 nous
sommes passés après 2000 hectares en
2022 cultivé du chanvre mais pourquoi
faire tout presque si on en croit
cesélateurs t-shirt n'a pas pied le
chanvre est encore utilisé pour produire
des fibres textiles et permet aussi de
fabriquer du papier sans abattre
d'arbres
est apparu également le béton de chanvre
un matériau de construction biosourcée
dans les propriétés isolantes en font
aujourd'hui impression à tout puis des
fibres encore plus techniques notamment
dans l'industrie automobile sont devenus
des alternatives aux fibres de verre
beaucoup plus polluants
les graines riches en protéines sont
utilisables dans l'alimentation animale
comme humaine cette plante est donc au
coeur de nombreuses innovations d'une
forte demande sociale et d'opportunités
économiques j'ai relevé plus de 600
produits dérivés brevetés dans le monde
dont la moitié proviennent
malheureusement toujours de Chine
d'autres pays ont bien compris l'intérêt
de cette culture et ce sont d'ores et
déjà saisi de cette chance de
développement à titre d'exemple lorsque
les États-Unis ont décidé de soutenir la
filière ils sont passés de 9000 à 33000
hectares en un an
un autre tour nous devons soutenir cette
filière et créer un écosystème favorable
avec des règles claires et surtout des
passionnants le débat autour du
caractère psychotrope du cannabis fibre
graines la plante vous le savez a aussi
des feuilles et des fleurs se pose alors
un problème de réglementation au sujet
du chanvre bien-être laquelle parait à
ce jour assez confuse
autorisé par l'Europe la
commercialisation des fleurs et feuilles
a été suspendue par un arrêté lequel a
été invalidé par le Conseil d'État en
janvier dernier la Cour de cassation
quant à elle à légaliser la
commercialisation de ces produits bref
si nous voulons une filière française
d'excellence celle des extraits de
chambre il s'agit de donner à nos
entreprises la possibilité d'investir
sereinement et pleinement ces marchés
d'avenir en clarifiant les
réglementations applicables aux
différents produits finis et on les
alignant sur celles de nos homologues
européen et britanniques pour jouer à
arnégal si le chanvre a une croissance
très simple depuis la plantation jusqu'à
la récolte cette dernière nécessite un
matériel spécifique et un temps
d'intervention plus long que la majorité
des cultures la graine est en fragile et
la paille demandant plusieurs
interventions avant sa transformation la
culture du chanvre nécessite donc des
outils spécialisés et donc des
investissements or les investissements
demeureront frileux tant que les règles
ne sont pas claires ni pérennes la
position de la France c'est le reste
figée reviendra donc à favoriser nos
pays voisins sans aucune justification
rationnelle il y a un an nous avions eu
un débat ici même sur ce sujet le
gouvernement annonçait sa volonté je
cite de mettre en place un cadre
réglementaire pour permettre le
développement sécurisé de la filière
force et de constater que le dossier n'a
pas bougé
mais pourquoi attendre la loi de
transition énergétique demande de
concevoir des bâtiments à énergie
positives faisant en sorte que ces
matériaux de construction bien sourcées
soit sur notre marché mes chers
collègues ou leur a donc compris si tout
est bon dans le cochon c'est le cas du
chanvre aussi je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Dominique fort
secrétaire d'État chargé de la ruralité
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la Commission
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
dois reconnaître au groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire et à son président
Guillaume Gontard une constance qui
l’honore puisque le Sénat avait initié
ce débat important sur l'avenir de la
filière du chanvre en février dernier à
votre initiative cette proposition de
résolution va nous permettre
d'approfondir les échanges que vous
aviez alors eu avec le gouvernement et
montre par la diversité des soutiens
qu'elle a recueilli sur ses bandes toute
l'importance de ce sujet ainsi que ça
complexité cela a été dit il s'agit je
crois d'un point de consensus mais je me
permets de souligner à nouveau le
chanvre est une filière dont nous devons
soutenir le développement en raison des
opportunités qu'elle offre d'un point de
vue
agroécologique il s'agit en effet d'une
culture qui nécessite une quantité
relativement limitée d'azote pas
d'irrigation hors conditions climatiques
exceptionnelles du fait de ses racines
profondes elle ne nécessite aucun
traitement phytosanitaire ce qui lui
fait également de la biomasse produite
en fait un réservoir de biodiversité
d'insectes et d’anthropodes dont
notamment des espèces régulatrices des
ravageurs de culture
en outre le chanvre participe à
l'allongement des rotations des
exploitations de grandes cultures et à
la diversité des assolements enfin
l'utilisation de plus en plus répandue
de ces produits dans le bâtiment ont
fait un produit agricole contribuant à
stocker du carbone au lieu d'en émettre
en cela sera important de veiller à ce
que l'amour agricole soit bien considéré
dans le calcul des crédits carbone
générés l'enjeu est que les producteurs
soient équitablement rémunérés par la
vente de ces crédits carbone ce qui
participera à l'attractivité de la
culture du chanvre pour nos agriculteurs
nous veillerons donc à ce que cela soit
bien pris en compte
par le Comité Scientifique et Technique
du label bacarbone dans les
méthodologies de calcul pour le chanvre
pour le chanvre et plus gros globalement
pour les biomasse agricoles valorisés
dans les autres secteurs industriels je
voudrais vous assurer que mon collègue
Marco
euvre
efficativement en faveur du
développement de la filière au ministère
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire à travers le dialogue
constant qui l'entretient avec
interchange l'interprofession mais aussi
financièrement outre les aides
classiques de la politique agricole
commune la filière chambre bénéficie
d'une aide de couplet 96 euros à
l'hectare si la production est
contractualisée et que la variété est
certifiée en tout cas les enjeux sont
majeurs pour la France premier
producteur de chambre au niveau européen
mais aussi mondiale le développement de
la filière chanvre n'est d'ailleurs pas
uniquement un objectif que nous devons
nous fixer en matière agricole et
alimentaire puisque les débouchés
qu'elle offre peuvent constituer des
atouts intéressants pour notre pays en
matière énergétique écologique ou
industrielle dans un contexte
d'accroissement je vais juste
interrompre deux secondes excusez-moi
sincèrement je vais vous demander quand
même un peu de respect
et de parler tous un peu plus bas ou de
d'écouter madame la ministre je vous
remercie
dans un contexte d'accroissement des
surfaces qui ont été multipliées par
trois en disant la culture du chanvre
alimentation de nombreux marchés qui
vont de la papeterie à l'automobile du
bâtiment au jardinage en passant par la
plasturgie l'alimentation animale et
humaine ou encore le textile j'ajoute il
s'agit d'un point qui me semble
absolument essentiel du point de vue du
dynamisme et de la vitalité économique
de nos territoires notamment ruraux que
la filière se caractérise notamment par
l'existence d'un grand nombre d'acteurs
de taille modestes fonctionnant en
circuit court avec un ancrage
territorial particulièrement fort j'y
suis comme vous profondément attaché la
proposition de résolution examinée
aujourd'hui s'inscrit résolument dans
cette logique de soutien au
développement de la filière chanvre en
France et le gouvernement estime que
cette initiative sénatoriale
viendra utilement enrichir les
réflexions à mener dans cette
perspective le ministère de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire est prêt à continuer à
travailler en lien très étroit avec le
Sénat sur cette dimension agricole du
sujet j'en viens maintenant au second
volet de cette proposition de résolution
qui concerne le sujet qui dépasse
largement le champ de l'agriculture
celui de l'amélioration de la
réglementation des produits
issus du chanvre il s'agit d'un sujet
auquel le gouvernement apporte une
attention toute particulière et sur
lequel loin des caricatures qui peuvent
parfois caractérisés ces débats ce n'est
pas ici le cas bien sûr nous souhaitons
poser les enjeux avec exigences et
méthodes je voudrais en premier lieu
aller dans le sens de ce qui a été dit
par plusieurs orateurs oui il existe
incontestablement des enjeux autour de
la réglementation des produits issus du
chanvre dont la consommation de
cannabidiol
mais donc il existe un contestablement
des enjeux autour de cette
réglementation des produits issus du
champ et naturellement le plus évident
mais pas le seul ces sujets importants
ont été posés avec plus d'acuités encore
avec la suspension par le Conseil d'État
du cadre réglementaire global dont la
France c'était dotée ce dernier devrait
devait permettre le développement
sécurisé de la filière agricole du champ
ainsi que des activités économiques
liées à la production d'extrait de
chanvre à la commercialisation de
produits qui les intègre tout en
garantissant la protection des
consommatrices et des consommateurs et
le maintien de la capacité
opérationnelle des forces de sécurité
intérieure dans la lutte contre les
trafics de stupéfi de stupéfiants
l'absence d'une réglementation claire
sous la ville est vraie un certain
nombre de difficultés et plus
spécifiquement j'en citerai 3 une forme
d'instabilité pour les acteurs de la
filière que ce soit le monde agricole
industriel l'élaboratoires ou le
commerce de détails qui manquent de
visibilité dans la conduite de leur
projet économique deuxièmement une
commercialisation possible en France
mais avec une immense majorité de fleurs
et d'extrait commercialisés issus de
l'importation ce qui est un enjeu pour
notre filière pour notre filière et sa
place de leader troisièmement un sujet
de sécurité en termes de consommation
car je tiens le souligner ici si le
cannabidiol n'est pas classé comme un
stupéfiant il s'agit tout de même d'une
substance à effet psycho-actif dont les
risques pour la santé sont encore en
cours d'expertise partant de ces
constats je voudrais partager avec vous
quelques éléments de réflexion en
premier lieu que nous dit le Conseil
d'État que les produits dont la teneur
en tétra hydrocanabinol THC n'est pas
supérieur à 0,3% ne revêtent pas un
degré de nocivité pour la santé
justifiant une mesure d'interdiction
générale et absolue de leur vente et de
leur consommation en effet il n'est pas
il n'a pas été établi que le CBD est
dangereux à cette date à ce stade mais
il n'y a pas non il n'a pas non plus été
établi scientifiquement qu'il ne l'est
pas dans quelle limite de consommation
il ne l'est pas c'est la raison pour
laquelle je nous invite collectivement à
la prudence sur ce sujet mais aussi au
travail scientifique mène actuellement
l'Autorité européenne de sécurité des
aliments car il nous semble que seul la
science doit éclairer nos décisions
s'agissant d'un sujet aussi délicat il
s'agit je crois du chemin que nous
devons emprunter sans précipitation
deuxièmement je tiens à souligner quand
l'état actuel de la réglementation les
services de police et de gendarmerie
seront recherchés relevés les
infractions comme la provocation même
non suivi des faits à l'usage illicite
de stupéfiants il n'est pas acceptable
par exemple que des publicités en faveur
du cannabidiol entretiennent la
confusion avec le cannabis et font ainsi
indirectement la promotion de ce
stupéfiant en dépit de la suspension de
certaines dispositions de l'arrêté du 31
décembre 2021 nous ne sommes donc pas
dans un no man's land juridique
s'agissant de ce sujet et nous sommes
bel et bien en mesure de lutter contre
tout ce qui peut s'apparenter à la
promotion et à la banalisation du
cannabis il s'agit je le rappelle de la
manière la plus claire possible de la
position ferme et constante du
gouvernement sur ces sujets
naturellement au-delà de ces réponses
qui sont absolument nécessaires des
réflexions interministérielles sont en
cours sur ceux qui pourraient constituer
une politique de contrôle abouti sur la
commercialisation des extraits de
chanvre certaines des orientations de
cette proposition de résolution pourrait
d'ailleurs en partie s'intégrer dans le
cadre de ces réflexions je vois trois
enjeux assez contrôles qui relèvent de
la compétence à la fois de de nos
services et des services de la DGCCRF le
premier de contrôler l'absence de
pratiques commerciales trompeuses et de
tromperie sur les qualités
substantielles du produit relevant du
Code de la Consommation notamment en cas
d'alégation trompeuse et notamment
d'alégation de santé non autorisée ou
thérapeutique en lien avec l'utilisation
d'extrait de chambre le deuxième enjeu
est de donner des informations
au consommateur sur les bonnes pratiques
d'utilisation et les publics pour
lesquels la consommation d'extraits de
champ est à éviter jeunes enfants femmes
enceintes enfin il y a un enjeu à
réaliser des contrôles aléatoires sur
les produits commercialisés en France
afin de vérifier notamment l'absence de
contamination des extraits par le THC et
éviter ainsi des risques de santé
publique
ces produits n'échapperont pas au
retrait et rappelle en cas de
non-conformité j'ajoute s'agissant du
ministère de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire qu'un nouveau
conseil scientifique piloté par
l'interprofession interchange a été créé
en février 2022 afin d'accompagner au
mieux les agriculteurs qui souhaitent
produire les fleurs de chanvre trois
groupes de travail ont été constitués
sur la génétique sur l'itinéraire
technique du chanvre à destination de la
production de fleurs sur la mécanisation
de la récolte des fleurs une feuille de
route et donc en cours de définition
enfin je tiens tout de même
à vous faire partager des interrogations
sur les conséquences agricoles
alimentaires et environnementales que
pourrait avoir un développement débridé
des débouchés liés à la consommation de
cannabidiol et autre extraits de chant
qui se vendent à prix d'or
allons-nous nous nourrir d'extrait de
chambre à ce jour la production de
chambre à fleurs est bien distincte de
celle du chanvre destiné à la production
de graines et de fibres il nous
appartient ainsi de peser les
conséquences d'un tel choix sur les
autres débouchés qui pourraient
mécaniquement perdre de leur
attractivité parfois déjà fragile je
pense en particulier à l'alimentation
humaine et animale qui est un enjeu de
souveraineté alimentaire ou encore à
l'isolation des bâtiments en jeu
d'indépendance énergétique et de
transition écologique or ce sont bien
ces priorités qui sont à l'agenda des
priorités du gouvernement vous l'aurez
compris mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs sans en partager la totalité
des orientations en particulier
s'agissant des préconisations formulées
sur la réglementation des produits issus
du champ le gouvernement considère que
cette proposition de résolution est très
utile au débat et se saisira du vote au
Sénat pour poursuivre et accélérer les
réflexions indispensables à un
développement maîtrisé et ambitieux de
la filière je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
alors nous allons procéder au vote sur
la proposition de résolution la
conférence dépressive des présidents a
décidé que les interventions des
orateurs valaient explications de vote
j'ai été saisie d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe écologiste sur la
proposition de résolution il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
ok plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
si la voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 55 sur l'ensemble du texte
contenu de l'ensemble des délégations de
vote accordée par les sénateurs au
groupe politique et notifié à la
présidence nombre de votants 208 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 186 pour
l'adoption 179 contre 7 le Sénat à
adopter
je vais suspendre la séance vraiment
quelques instants pour permettre à
chacun de s'installer pour l'examen du
prochain point à l'ordre du jour la
séance est suspendue